there stands a good chance that avengers
endgame might mark the final film for
several Marvel favorites but in the
weeks leading up to the film's launch
the cast is keeping their minds off such
grim outcomes the endgame press tour has
been filled with both laughter and
emotional moments however there's no
escaping the fact that the end is nigh
and that Earth's Mightiest Heroes will
face a dangerous fight in endgame one
member of the endgame team who isn't
letting the rest of the cast forget that
harrowing reality is none other than
thinnest actor Josh Brolin who has
delivered a terrifying reminder to his
fellow MCU stars taking to Instagram
Brolin posted a photo of a set chair
with the mad Titans name written on it
plus the Infinity Gauntlet carefully
sitting atop the seats back he wrote in
the caption when you all are done with
your interviews and your talk shows I'll
slip this perfectly fitting gauntlet
back on and tell you a story about your
future he's pretty good that right
just as Brolin's post hints the avengers
endgame crew has been incredibly busy
promoting the in samba pick and what
they haven't been able to do during
those events is ironically talk about
what's coming in endgame if they even
know themselves I didn't even get a
whole script I don't know why I even got
the script I did get had-had dummy
scenes in it
Marvel is keeping an airtight lid on
endgame details and for good reason as
the studio doesn't want to ruin the
movie-going experience for anyone or
risk damaging what's meant to be the
culmination of 11 years of stories in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that's it
the interviews the endgame stars are
giving are essentially hype boosters
rather than detailed dishing 'he's in
some ways the lack of plot specifics and
the hesitancy to talk too much about
endgame is a distraction from the
inevitable the undusted heroes are all
but guaranteed to go head-to-head with
Thanos once more still everyone knows
that's coming the endgame teasers
specifically the most recent special
look trailer point toward the Avengers
crafting a plan to take down the mad
Titan reverses decimation and resurrect
the fallen heroes plus the billions upon
billions of other lives that were lost
post snap what that mission entails is a
total mystery though a theory that has
gained more traction than others is that
the team will gear up in the
new suits which looked kinda similar to
the one hank pym wore in the quantum
realm and ant-man in the wasp and travel
back in time to stop Thanos from ever
coming close to getting his hands on the
Infinity Gauntlet another notion is
grounded in something Captain Marvel
said in the latest look at endgame so
that's gonna use them to bring everyone
back just like that yeah
the heroes may not turn back the clock
but instead remain in the existing
timeline journeying through space to rip
the Infinity stones straight from Thanos
his hand speaking of the Infinity
Gauntlet there's also the idea that the
mystical armored glove won't be as
powerful in endgame as it was in the
final moments of infinity war which saw
both the gauntlet and Thanos arms
suffered damage as a result of the snap
the glimpses at endgame we've gotten so
far hint that the gauntlet is charred
and the Russo brothers previously
revealed that quote the power that it
takes to use all six stones is
significant and clearly damaged the
gauntlet and damaged Thanos Joe Russo
added during a Q&A session following a
screening of infinity war that Thanos
his arm is burned and explains that the
damage extends to other parts of his
body including anything that's on his
arm like the Infinity Gauntlet Russo
said the physical price is the extreme
power that it took to enact his plan he
paid for it physically and when he sits
down on the steps at the end of the
movie you can see that it actually
carries up into his neck and onto his
face his arm is dug and anything
attached to his arm is up so even though
Thanos will eventually slip the gauntlet
back on and spin a terrifying tale about
what his vision and the future holds for
the heroes
he didn't kill in his decimation there's
a chance that the damage he has already
done to the gauntlet and to his own body
will throw a wrench in his overall plan
whatever that may be
right now the ratio of answered
questions to unsolved mysteries
surrounding Avengers endgame is pretty
low and no matter how hard we speculate
about what could happen in the film the
only way to get the truth is to wait
patiently until the film opens in
theaters on April 26th you know what
that means we're gonna
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Avengers endgame are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]